все сильные и успешные люди этого мира
успешно пользуются этим инструментом
Если вы на не научитесь пользоваться
этим инструментом то вы потеряете в
своей жизни очень много Сегодня я хотел
бы с вами поговорить об одиночестве и о
том какую пользу приносит одиночество и
насколько одиночество влияет на вашу
эффективность большинство людей целыми
днями гоняются за успехом они заняты они
у них Каждая минута расписана они всё
время тусуются они всё время в обществе
они что-то делают либо в офисе либо там
совещания либо тусовки форумы и так
далее и так далее и они думают что чем
больше они проводят времени в обществе
среди людей а делают бизнес и так далее
То тем выше их эффективность у меня у
самого есть парочка друзей которые не
любят одиночество и когда я предлагаю им
поехать куда-нибудь в степь и так далее
они всё время говорят что они заняты На
что я с ухмылкой им говорю на самом деле
Вы не заняты а вы боитесь одиночества и
Свободы И что здесь не так и почему
одиночество настолько важно особенно Я
заметил это что многие успешные и
сильные люди используют этот инструмент
и очень часто остаются один на один с
собой Сегодня я хотел бы с вами
поделиться семью основными советами э
или лайфхаками как использовать
Одиночество в свою пользу и Что даёт
Одиночество в вашей жизни Итак переходим
а пункт первый сила одиночества в том
что одиночество возвращает нам
естественность во время одиночества мы
приходим как бы к себе мы вынуждены быть
честными сами с собой потому что нам
некому что-то доказывать нам не надо ни
перед кем держать марку мы можем быть
максимально естественными с собой и нам
сложно Я бы сказал невозможно врать
самим себе потому что какой смысл из
себя что-то строить какой смысл что-то
себе врать и кстати это одна из причин
Почему многие люди боятся одиночества
они на самом деле живут в мире своих
иллюзий и им реально страшно Остаться
один на один с собой потому что придётся
прямо Взглянуть на себя и на свои
проблемы поэтому не избегайте
одиночества даже хотя бы ради этого
первого пункта потому что одиночество
возвращает вас к самому себе возвращает
вас в Ваше естественное состояние второй
пункт
одиночество восстанавливает гармонию
между вашим умом и вашим сердцем
одиночество восстанавливает связь между
вашим мозгом и вашей душой а вы знаете
когда вы стремитесь к чему-то И хотите
чего-то достичь если не будет гармонии
между вашим умом или сознанием и
подсознанием либо между вашим умом и
вашим сердцем то наверняка вы этого не
достигнете потому что внутренние
противоречия будет вас разрывать и вы
будете нерешительные в своих действиях
вы будете имитация то ли Вот так делать
то ли по-другому поэтому для успешного
продвижения вперёд или достижения целей
очень важна гармония ума и сердца это
очень важно и гармония вашего сознания с
подсознанием и одиночество именно тот
инструмент который восстанавливает эту
гармонию И связь третий пункт Почему
важно и полезно одиночество Дело в том
что когда человек находится в
одиночестве он может сверить свой компас
я называю с четырьмя контролёра с
четырьмя своими контролёра первый
контролёр - это конечно же Всевышний
когда человек в одиночестве он может
представить как он выглядит в глазах
Всевышнего что по его мнению думает
Всевышний о нём вот Подумайте сделайте
себе такое упражнение выберите какой-то
час одиночество Или 15 минут хотя бы и
поразмышляйте именно на эту тему Как вы
думаете что думает Всевышний Жизни Как
вы думаете что Всевышний думает о ваших
поступках Это первый ваш контролёр во
время одиночества Вы можете сверить
компас со вторым своим контролёром
второй контролёр ваш - Это ваша совесть
только в одиночестве Вы можете услышать
свою совесть Поэтому останьтесь в
одиночестве послушайте своё сердце
послушайте сво свою совесть и она Вам
скажет правильно вы действуете или нет
Это тот компас К сожалению
чувствительность которого очень
име ваша чувствительность к нему и вы в
повседневной жизни не ощущаете и не
замечаете этого у некоторых людей это
сильно развито А у некоторых людей
несильно и повседневна ежедневная
беготня и суета она заглушает голо
совести и одиночество позволяет услышать
второго своего контролёра под названием
ваша совесть третий ваш контролёр
одиночество позволяет вам остановиться и
подумать что о васма
это третий контролёр Когда вы
представляете как вы выглядите в глазах
других людей Когда вы представляете что
люди будут говорить на ваших похоронах
вы знаете Это очень важное и нужное
упражнение и это упражнение возможно
сделать только в одиночестве и четвёртый
ваш контролёр который тоже не менее
важен и общение с которым для вас очень
важно Это сверка с вашими мечтами то
есть четвёртый ваш контролёр - это тот
мечтатель ребёнок который сидит в вашей
душе и только в одиночестве Вы можете
поговорить с ним и спросить осуществили
ли вы свои мечты или нет Поговорите
обязательно с ним выберите время
Поговорите со своим мечтателем ребёнком
который находится в вашей душе и это ваш
четвёртый контролёр с которым вы можете
поговорить во время одиночества
четвёртый пункт Почему одиночество очень
важно и полезно одиночество
позволяет вам Взглянуть на ваши истинные
намерения позволяет вам задаться
вопросом вообще кто я для чего я живу
куда я иду что делаю представить свои
истинные намерения потому что в суете
дня мы часто совершаем поступки и делаем
дела даже не задумываясь о намерениях у
нас есть цель и мы идём к ней и наши
намерения мы не контролируем в то время
как вы должны тко понимать что люди
судят по делам а Всевышний судит по
намерениям и очень важно проверять
правильно ли и хорошие ли у вас
намерения или нет приведу вам пример вот
Представьте такую ситуацию что ребёнок
бежит с горячим чаем споткнулся и пролил
на вас горячий чай вы
вскакивает Я же вам сколько раз я тебе
говорил не бегать по дому с горячим чаем
и так далее и так далее но вы раздражены
и это вы высказали и какой урок ребёнок
получил ребёнок получил ругань от отца в
то время как он бежал и спешил принести
горячий чай маме и у него в голове
подсознательно складывается цепочка что
Вот его хорошее намерение подать горячий
чай маме получила такое неодобрение или
ругани со стороны отца это всё
подсознательно фиксируется в голове у
ребёнка смотрите это тот случай который
показывает что мы судим по делам но
Всевышний нас будет судить на том свете
по нашим намерением в исламе даже
сказано что если человек задумается
плохое дело и сделает его то Аллах это
зачёт как одно плохое дело если он
задумается плохое дело и не сделает его
то Аллах зачёт это как хорошее дело если
человек задумается хорошее дело и не
сделает его то Аллах защит это как
сделанное хорошее дело а если человек
задумается хорошее дело и сделает его то
награда может быть
бесчисленное очень а обязательно
внимательно думайте над своим намерением
Когда вы что-либо делаете и одиночество
это именно та пауза в течение которого
вы можете подвергнуть ревизии ревизии
все свои дела и проверить правильные ли
у вас намерения или нет пятый пункт
польза одиночества - это то что
одиночество позволяет вам хорошо усвоить
полученные знания и глубже понять
какие-то новые знания знания не
усваиваются в процессе получения Вот вы
посмотрели какое-то видео либо
аудиоподкаст и если вы не дали После
этого паузу а сразу начали смотреть
другое видео или слушать другой
аудиоподкаст то Поверьте мне предыдущие
знания они не усвоили они просто
пропадают Они записались вам в
краткосрочную память и когда вы смотрите
следующее видео Они тут же стираются из
краткосрочной памяти как
видеорегистратора автомобиля и сверху
записывается новое видео таким образом
вы просто сжигайте своё время
обязательно делайте паузы А и именно
пауза одиночества в которого в течение
которого поразмышляйте о том видео
которое вы только что просмотрели даже
если вы посмотрели видео И даже если вы
просто 5 минут 10 минут посидите в
одиночестве и поразмышляйте над той
информацией которую вы получили эта
информация эти знания усвоят вами
гораздо глубже шестой пункт в пользу
одиночества - это то что одиночество
рождает новые мысли и новые знания в
древнем санскрите об этом пишется есть
такая практика называется тапас тапас -
это рождение знаний Так вот там у них
есть такая практика когда человек
удаляется в одиночество и смысл такой в
одиночество и он есть тапас речи когда
он закрывает свой рот и не не
разговаривает неделю либо Тапа слуха
когда он закрывает уши и неделю Никого
не слушает Тапа зрения когда он закры
гза и неделю ничего не видит вы знаете
эти вещи приводят во-первых к обострению
других органов чувств а второе индусы
говорят что тапас с Древне
санскритских сказал предыдущие они
возможны только в том случае когда у вас
не просто одиночество А когда вас ничто
не отвлекает и ничто не раздражает когда
вы достаточно зрелые для того чтобы быть
честным хотя бы перед самим собой потому
что есть люди которые могут механически
выполнить Это упражнение а уйти в
одиночество но бояться взглянуть правде
в глаза и
э занимаются самообмана то есть они
недостаточно зрелые чтобы взглянуть
правди в глаза и быть честным самим
собой поэтому одиночество приносит
пользу только в том случае если вас
ничто не отвлекает второе когда вас
ничего не раздражает третье Когда вы
достаточно зрелый для того чтобы быть
честным самим собой четвёртое Когда вы
готовы взять ответственность всю
ответственность за свою жизнь и за всё
что в ней происходит и вот этот шестой
пункт я бы сказал бы вернее седьмой
пункт он является условиям при которых
вот эти предыдущие шесть пунктов польза
одиночества работают лу всего не
пытайтесь
просто сделать механически уйти в
одиночество обязательно соблюдайте эти
условия и тогда вы будете извлекать из
одиночества максимум И поверьте мне
Одиночество - это сильнейший инструмент
и я например
одиночество предпочитаю наверное больше
чем находиться В какой-то тусовке Мне
очень нравится находиться в одиночестве
и размышлять и я вам рекомендую этот
инструмент как инструмент с высокой
эффективностью уверен у каждого из вас
есть свои истории связанные с
одиночеством кто-то абсолютно не любит
одиночества Напишите в комментариях
почему вы не любите одиночество есть
люди которые боятся одиночества тоже
Напишите Почему вы боитесь одиночества
что вы боитесь там услышать или увидеть
и это кстати очень важно потому что
благодаря этому Вы можете разрешить
многие свои проблемы Напишите также в
комментариях Если вы любите одиночество
или во время одиночества вам приходили
какие-то озарения Поделитесь своим
опытом чтобы другие почитали и
посмотрели и действительно убедились что
одиночество - это очень крайне полезный
инструмент Если вы спросите меня А как
на практике я применяю одиночество Дело
в том что это не так чтобы я вот как
знаете как в отпуск собираюсь там
чемоданы пакую и потом ухожу в
одиночество Нет на самом деле даже в
течение дня у меня есть периоды чёткие
периоды одиночества например Когда я
утром просыпаюсь я как минимум минут 30
нахожусь ещё в постели во-первых я
проговаривая про себя аффирмации и я про
себя а ну часто слушаю себя свои мысли
мечты вот те пункты о которых я сегодня
вам говорил это такой короткий
промежуток одиночества дальше когда я
смотрю какое-то видео обучающее я это
обычно смотрю в одиночестве но это не
является ещё одиночеством но я смотрю
это видео а потом отключаю видео и один
по кабинету и или по дому по террасе
хожу и размышляю над этим видео и это
тоже можно отнести к одиночеству когда
меня ничто не отвлекает ни уведомления
ни раздражители ничто не отвлекает и я
могу спокойно один походить и
поразмышлять на той информации которую я
только что получил одиночество Может
быть когда вы вы например делаете
короткий какой-то отдых Ну например или
отдых или просто занимаетесь спортом Ну
вот как я например а взяли и пошли э
ходить пешком вот я часто хожу там час
полтора два пешком здесь по горам
соответственно это тоже одиночество
которое я применяю очень часто Я вообще
предпочитаю ходить один у меня даже
когда супруга идёт со мной она одевает
наушники Она слушает свои аудио Подкасты
и так далее и мы Ну не всегда
разговариваем Когда ходим по горам это
тоже такой своеобразно одиночество Меня
ничто не отвлекает Меня ничто не
раздражает и я могу находясь на природе
разговаривать сам с собой обращаться к
своей душе и общаться со своими четырьмя
контролёра поэтому одиночество - это не
что-то такое отдельное мероприятие - это
то что в течение дня вы можете вставлять
э в своё расписание поэтому А применяйте
этот инструмент сумом и главное
подходите осознанно к нему хотите больше
узнать о каких-то других практиках
мышления и того как использовать
одиночество переходите в мой Telegram
канал ссылку я оставляю внизу